I just wanna let everyone know that I
hope you're having a great night tonight
yes but please try out a step out of
life or I will not hesitate to put you
in a rear naked choke hi there I'm Aria
and we're here at the incredible austin
powers themed bar the electric pussycat
where I'll be working as a bouncer for
the night also makes sense in a moment I
know you're probably wondering about the
piggy yeah what is going on with that
you get ruffians out there they want to
do our shakedown the establishment
extort whatever you know these hooligans
do but then they see someone decked out
like this I mean what would you do if
you saw someone watching a place Oh
possibly think twice or saying what you
got is it's not Halloween is it it is
security so you want to make sure that
people are having a good time but in a
fashionable manner you know I know
hooligans or you know some knuckleheads
getting out of line but at the same time
you got to realize that you want to have
a good time we've all been out but
keeping it reasonable I've never really
been a big club goer so tonight
I'm looking forward to getting a fresh
perspective on nightlife from the other
side of the ropes but unfortunately as
much as Robert admires Mikey it doesn't
quite fit with their dress code so I
have to quickly pot next door for an
outfit change with one minor adjustment
if things get rowdy what's like protocol
so if you're being destructive to
property you know and being belligerent
and being too intoxicated those are
signs that your immediate
yeah you know where's you know you're
bumping into the chairs that you'll see
later on upstairs okay they'll get a
warning play if they're like okay well
you you know then okay you gotta go
possibly if they swing at you then I
would say yeah I've been training like
all week look at that okay
look at that just for tonight huh the
co-worker Meredith but soon after my
shift starts I suddenly get my first
taste of the dangers I'm facing tonight
there's one lady tried sneaking in the
moment Ashton was like oh she's going
it's like time Stood Still and I was
just get back here please it's scary to
think that if she got in and let's say
you know she like assaulted someone know
who's responsible me me but luckily as
the night goes on I begin to find my
groove
[Music]
wow that's a great idea oh gee I like a
headshot photographer you can recommend
no are you doing that a great night yeah
I'm a really good night - you know what
make it even more fun though because if
we if we had some methamphetamine
unfortunately that's not like oh you you
don't have any on you no no no heroin
good anybody out fortunately man I got
some photos I need to show you they
don't feel think twice you know we
should get those photos I don't think
you need to do it I think we get booked
I think we do I can we get those photos
blown up and we just like put them
against the wall I'm running out of
battery you know like constantly having
to show people to photos yeah I'm gonna
take you in right now we're about to do
a sweep of the club Austin and the go-go
dancers just hit the stage right now so
we want to make sure that they're able
to do their thing not being interrupted
by any of the guests trying to go on
stage nobody's throwing money trying to
be obnoxious either is that that does
happen sometimes and then we're gonna go
up to the VIP area
take a look make sure it's not
overcrowded we're gonna be able to guide
the line making sure our cocktail
servers are able to get to our clients
to be able to get their drinks efficient
as possible the things that I mentioned
earlier I want you to go ahead and be on
the lookout for it
b14 see so what's wrong with that okay
true and if you need to take action you
can take action maybe I put someone a
rear naked choke do anything you saw
anything
hey let's settle down here give that my
ballot this place safe we want you guys
to have a good time but we can only have
one person for a booth and please try
not to swing okay but even though we
were luckily able to avert that crisis
on our sweep our cameras captured a
suspicious-looking man who is now on my
radar but not wanting to burden Robert I
decide to launch my own covert
investigation and to help me on this
task I quickly call in PD plastic an
actor I once hired off of Craigslist
have you ever hooked up with anyone in
the club oh it several many times and
save drums bathroom Edition so I saw
some upstairs that was acting you know a
little suspicious
borderline belligerent unfortunately he
saw me so I can't do it undercover
operation but I'd love for you to maybe
you know look into this for me and if
things get out of hand I'll be there
don't worry typical night out I got the
we could be saving lives here but the
clock racing against us PD begins his
hunt for this delinquent we need to act
fast because who knows where he might be
and when he might decide to cause a
scene but finally PD spots him and moves
in I have a quick question for you
they're not planning on attacking anyone
no no good I'm glad he is not trying to
attack anybody so we're all safe and
good are you sure do you see him did you
look him in the eyes right him dead in
the eyes and I saw and it was just
perfectly fine close call
thankfully it looks like we have the
situation under control and as relief
washes over me I'm able to enjoy the
rest of the night completing my duties
how do you feel the security the bar is
so far the security of the bar is
fantastic so far how would you say I've
been doing he's doing a great goddamn
job I took the clothes for you Robert oh
is that right and in fact as the night
comes to a close I'm genuinely
disappointed that the evening has gone
by so quickly thank you so much hey well
thank you very much I appreciate it
overall I would say good job because you
follow direction and you listened and
you knew what to look for that's why
you're able to find some of the things
that we had mentioned earlier you're
very enthusiastic and people respond to
that as a chance I could keep this
flashlight absolutely that's all yours
there you go I'm so happy right now
so from electric pussycat Robert and
Aria bye-bye
happy birthday to
happy birthday dear David as moral to
you